let me pull up this uh tweet from former
disinformation zarnina jankowicz she
tweeted in a longer thread about a piece
that she had previously published in one
of her tweets in in the threat she says
since this piece was published in summer
2020 the spread and effects of
disinformation in american society
have only worsened and become entrenched
in domestic politics as the last few
weeks of my life has have shown
this is the type of work i had hoped to
do at dhs and the type of work the usgs
sorely needs to invest in this is the
type of work that i have built my career
on not a few context-less tweets and
this is the type of work i will continue
in the public sphere i said
disinformation specialist claims the u.s
disinformation board was to focus on
domestic issues a shocking admission
it really is now that she's out she's
outright saying oh all of this disinfo
was in american politics and that's what
i wanted to focus my work on
she responded i'd encourage you to read
the paper to me she said i'd encourage
you to read the paper that i'm
referencing which is entirely focused on
hostile state disinformation
she then responded to a few other people
the same thing saying the threat you're
citing which you've removed the initial
context to is in reference to a paper
about hostile state disinfo you can
disagree with my assessment that it
affects domestic politics discourse but
the strategy described in the paper is
the work i'm referring to
it's almost like she doesn't understand
i would assume she outright doesn't get
it or she's just lying
the issue is
there is no difference from what she
claims to be russian disinfo and typical
american politics
she is someone who has tweeted out the
russian disinformation line uncritically
without fact checking when it turns out
it was true the hunter biden laptop
story she says i i was just quoting what
the president said yes you were pushing
out disinformation without fact checking
without without any critical assessment
just repeating what the liar
joe biden was saying about his son and
the illicit deals they were doing if you
did any amount of work you would have
seen that there are illicit dealings
from hunter biden with barisma in
ukraine and china you would know about
joe biden flying his son in air force
two into china for private equity deals
but she's done no research on any of
this blindly pushes lies and then says i
want to work on these issues affecting
domestic politics but that's out of
context when you say my work would have
involved domestic politics if she thinks
the hunter biden laptop story
was misinformation or disinformation if
she was unwilling to actually look into
what that was as an expert on it she
absolutely was going to be interfering
with first amendment issues she doesn't
get it these are children who have no
experience who are not experts who just
think they're smarter than you being
given government jobs hey that sounds
like government in its entirety doesn't
it i don't know tim i think she did some
research she asked joe biden if he did
anything wrong his administration said
no so there you go mostly false yeah
well okay then
i stand corrected sheamus you know she
said that it was a bunch of state
disinformation i think she specified
it's a lot of corporate disinformation
too we really got to focus on the
corporations trying to take over the
world right now she said the hunter
biden laptop story what did you say was
it was a trump campaign product i
believe so yeah she's full of it it's
what she does she lies she entrenches
herself in domestic politics and says i
want to focus on this but you've removed
context this is the problem with these
people now of course you know uh respect
for her responding at all i invite her
on the show but she's unavailable she's
about to have a child i guess so all
right well you know congratulations to
you yeah i mean that's a legitimate
response as to why you can't come on the
show i'm not gonna a lot of people are
like she's scared she'll never come on
you know she's gonna have a kid i might
be busy yeah that's that's an acceptable
answer i mean honestly i don't think
she's lying about being pregnant or
anything like that but uh well we don't
have a disinformat disinformation board
to investigate it so without that we can
never know if she's pregnant or not it's
true what really bothers me is that
americans would get caught in the
crossfire of this or or collaterally
damaged by this disinformation
specialist hammering down on things that
they think are like foreign actors or
you know like how can you discern if
it's a 12 year old in russia with a vpn
or a 17 year old in dubuque iowa i mean
you ca they might think they can maybe
they think they do but i mean the
russian would want you to think it's
dubuque the dubuque i would want you to
think it's russian so like
who in their right mind thinks they have
the hammer on that you you look at all
the things that uh nina jankowicz is
about right and especially with the
laptop instance but but you know covid
all of that
these people aren't really trying to
stamp out disinformation obviously
they're just trying to stamp out any
competition with their disinformation
i mean i'm not saying that every
pronouncement that came out
regarding the laptop let's just say that
i think all of that was bs but
say with covid i think that to some
extent people were confused afraid they
said a lot of stupid things they refused
to walk them back and when they did they
pretended as if they were right the
whole time or if as if the situation was
evolving but at this point after two and
a half years of it really you know for
me 42 years of it but
two and a half years of it i i just see
no reason at all to take these people on
good faith totally at all
totally agreed and i've mentioned this
before on the show but
they argue that the science changes and
fair enough because science does change
but if you're gonna make that admission
and you're gonna fall back on that
whenever you have to change the
narrative you do not get to admonish
people for posting information that
conflicts with the narrative when you
have decided that that is the case at
least for the time being right so when
it comes to the lab leak hypothesis
that's the most famous and obvious
example they claim that that was
disinformation misinformation people
shouldn't be allowed to spread it then
as soon as it became more accepted for
people to believe that they were able to
absolve themselves of any wrongdoing by
saying well the information changed okay
fair enough information changes but then
you don't get to censor people who
present alternate information it's that
easy it's that easy
and that's that seems to be what their
intent is going to be what my prediction
for this information board apparently
it's still going on i don't know what
the latest details but it's not ending
they're going to issue a statement and
say oh you know that story about uh
hunter biden and those ladies of the
night that actually came from uh
where did it come from uh slovenia
uh so it we're gonna ban it and here's
our list and then twitter is gonna come
out and be like yeah that isn't allowed
to be tweeted uh twitter uh tweeted
twitter launched their crisis
disinformation policy
where they're actively editorializing i
mean at a certain point can we where
where's is there some like ultra rich
person who just firebombed your lawsuits
you know you know let me let me let me
tell you guys something you know the
most annoying thing about lawyers is
i think that's a hard the worst the
worst conversations i ever have are with
lawyers
they are by definition defeatist
every single conversation i've never had
a conversation with a lawyer who's like
i'm gonna go scorched earth no they go
well you know the thing about
this company is that under this statute
you're not going to win it's going to
cost you a lot of money so in reality
and i'm like
how does precedent get set
someone challenges the law someone files
a lawsuit a court issues their ruling it
goes up hits the appellate courts it
stops
times v sullivan the precedent by which
we have you know the standard for malice
and defamation or whatever
challenge it
but every single time i talk to a lawyer
about section 230 protections about uh
you know twitter outright saying our
staff will now determine what's true and
i'm like okay come on at a certain point
they have to like stepped over the line
right
here's what i hear
section 230 does not say that you aren't
allowed to edit you're allowed to do
good faith
moderation
230 actually protects that and then i'm
like okay which means we need a judge to
tell us to interpret the law to find out
what that limitation is not just sit
back and go i guess we can't do anything
ever yeah they've been slow to pick up
on that the last 15 years we need some
serious social media um i used to call
legislation or
law
law fair people really need to start
taking these social media networks
seriously well you know to the extent
they're a monopoly and i think they are
really a de facto monopoly
it certainly falls under the the first
amendment right i mean if these are
really if this consists of 80 to 90
percent of the public conversation it's
no longer private corporations these
people pretty much control all of the
information flow at that point let's
let's talk about wikipedia because i've
been going off on this one i'm i'm
really pissed off about this i don't
understand
well i think i do understand let me tell
you what's going on wikipedia publishes
every article under their byline
every single article says from wikipedia
right there i'm like present that
argument to a judge your honor i
understand section 230 protections that
you can't be held liable for what
someone else posts on your platform i'd
like to make the argument here that
wikipedia has assigned credit to
themselves for this article by putting
from wikipedia now if i put from tim
pool that's my byline i'm responsible
for that speech right well wikipedia has
done it i've heard the argument well you
can't because it's users who compile all
of this and i'm like okay let's break
down that standard real quick let me let
me let me break down what you're telling
me you're telling me that if i create an
automatic process by which i will
publish your articles under my name i
cannot be sued for defamation
so if i get ten thousand people right
now to all at one word
no one can be sued that is the stupidest
thing i have ever think about this you
could create a blank wiki titled um
nancy pelosi and then give everyone who
logs in the ability to add one word
based on the line let's do it let's
build this i'm not even kidding here's
what we'll do
let's develop
an uh a program where as soon as you
load the browser
it uh it puts you know it it knows
you're here to cookie or something so
you get one word to add based on your
position in line
you're the first person in you get to
have the first word haggard second
person can add the second word
high-heeled shoes oh that's just no
no one could be sued for defamation if
what ends up getting written by five
thousand people is nancy pelosi eats dog
if that was actually what was written
who are you gonna sue
nobody wrote it try suing five nope i
only wrote
wrote one word you can't sue me for
writing one word can you this is
nonsense the person who made the
platform that allows it to go out needs
to be responsible especially if
wikipedia is putting from wikipedia
under every article
but every time i talk to a lawyer i hear
the same thing well you can't because of
statute and i'm like okay get a
precedent because certainly if it's true
that you can't sue wikipedia or twitter
any of these platforms then there is no
longer any civil uh
uh civil tour or defamation clause none
of it none of it exists there's no
defamation you know what i want to
defend some defame somebody i'm just
going to be like here's an open forum
here's what we could do on timcast.com
we'll open up a comment section anybody
can write whatever they want in the
comments and then we'll just take them
all and paste them as a front page
article nice and whatever and
we'll grab a random user and we'll use
their sentence as the headline and
here's the best part only 10 people will
be granted special access to do so like
wikipedia wikipedia has special editors
who are allowed to lock and unlock pages
and have higher tiers they're given
special editing privileges but that
still is defamation proof okay
well let's make that and see what
happens here's my suggestion let's build
a system
here's how it works
it is blank
the first person to log in gets the
first word every time you load it you'll
be placed in line behind someone else
and if they don't write a word then
after 15 seconds their position expires
then you move up and you can add your
next word and then someone else can add
the next word and then you just get 50
000 people who all add one word to the
great news article that is i don't know
nancy pelosi or taylor lorenz or
whatever and then they can't do anything
about it then we'll put it on times
square billboard okay well first of all
that just sounds insanely fun i really
want to do that um and the second thing
is that this is an incredibly big
loophole that apparently no one else is
taking advantage of and i think that we
should absolutely do something like this
wikipedia is taking advantage of it
that's that's all wikipedia is now there
have been a lot of lawsuits against
wikipedia and i guess what happens is
two things they just settle right away
and when you settle
typically a judge is not going to
intervene he's going back you want it's
over in fact some judges might be like
you must settle we're not going to court
with this
and then if if wikipedia comes to you
and says how much do you want and you
say here's my damages they'll just be
okay done bye have a nice day we win
you know talking about the the
technological freight train that is
social media and the current media
ecosystem i mean what you're talking
about with wikipedia really is the same
sort of thing that you see with the new
york times washington post when they use
unnamed sources or they say such and
such said this and you know people's
lives have been destroyed by that so
many times people's reputations have
been completely sullied because once you
put out a story that says an unnamed
source said this or just simply this
person accuses this person of being a
racist or a rapist or whatever once
that's out there and they know this
that's what's going to be in the public
consciousness so i mean wikipedia is one
fine example but i would say that the
entire media ecosystem is is
it exemplifies how quickly
disinformation spreads and how little
accountability there is basically zero
there i don't think that you're ever
you're ever going to be able to stop
wrong information no the the issue is
when when it's completely automated or
when you wield institut institutional
power behind statute so twitter's
position of we're going to censor things
that we deem to be wrong i'm like okay
listen
if you as a platform i'm just going to
say if if your position is that
you pick and choose what content is seen
or not i don't care if random a random
person writes it if you decided so this
is not the standard a lot of
conservatives think the standard for 230
is you're either a platform or a
publisher that's not the standard it
should be the standard and we'd be we'd
be done then twitter would be like we're
not editorializing anything anymore no
more algorithms because if we intervene
in any way all of a sudden now we assume
liability for every statement ever good
that's how it should be that's not how
it is because of section 230. but you
know when i was talking about uh
localism regionalism uh we're you know
the kind of personal approach to
combating any sort of corrupt system
if you cultivate young people to be
critical to look at these things with if
at least a critical life not a cynical
eye you will have a generation that
comes up that's simply not subject to it
unfortunately i mean the educational
system is so eaten up with it i can
remember even 15 years ago wikipedia was
completely forbidden as a source to cite
now it's pretty much on the regular
people are you know
everything from undergrads possibly up
to the grad level who knows people are
encouraged to seek out these sorts of uh
we'll say
homogenized conformist sources
in the public you know in the public
education system i really do think
though that independent communities are
everything from radical catholics to you
know radical hippies uh to just you know
your average right
your average your average you know right
winger with a pistol i think that there
is this really deep cynicism and
skepticism towards the mainstream right
now and if that can be latched on
it will take time and but in time you
will have a generation that comes up
that's able to handle this that's able
to get on top of it i just want to i
want to stress this real quick before
moving on just so people can think about
it
if you go on wikipedia and you
contribute to an article say on ian and
you write you know ian once uh kicked a
dog he's a radical hippie you have made
a false statement against ian he did
never he did not do that and it causes
him damage all of a sudden he loses his
sponsorship from a local you know dog
pet dog store or something
then he's like i got damages and you and
you lied about me and you know you knew
you lied
you're gonna get sued for that but if
you go on with 10 friends and you write
ian and then your friend writes once and
then someone random guy says kicked
another person puts uh another person
puts a dog
no one can be sued because no one made a
statement
that's the that's that is insane and i
believe a judge would rule against that
immediately that's what wikipedia is
you can go into wikipedia and change a
single word someone will write ian once
kicked a
head of lettuce
and then someone can change lettuce to
dog head of dog
and they didn't say he did it they only
wrote one word so who's responsible for
defaming that's the problem with
wikipedia that's why i say
they should not have section 230
protections as it stands today because
it makes no sense
10 people all right one word then all of
a sudden no one said the word no one
said the phrase no wikipedia did
wait you can't
it's just so dumb like that wikipedia
can automate the defamation process and
then try and be absolved from it no no
no if you're listening and you feel like
you know filing lawsuits i think
somebody needs to file a lawsuit i don't
know
yeah i think wikipedia is amazing i use
it almost almost every day sometimes um
but you're right absolutely right about
that i just think about that
what a person could do
someone can write a long sentence saying
you know uh james o'keefe is a
journalist and
scholar and then someone can go in and
just change journalists to um
dog dog puncher i tried to i didn't say
it about him i just changed one word
after hillary clinton's emails came out
2016 or so on there about i i tried to
go to wikipedia and change it and be
like her emails implicated sydney
blumenthal you know osprey global
solutions setting up shop in libya and
immediately in like 10 seconds it was
removed so i don't know who's in charge
who's overseeing it it was it was true
stuff that i was looking at look up you
know hillary clinton sydney blumenthal
spray the global solution emails you'll
find it yeah i mean there's there's
definitely a slant there obviously who
was the
one of the guys who helped form
wikipedia pointed this out that when it
was formed under the ideals of community
you know just community contributions
creating this amazing platform they were
sincere and it really wikipedia used to
be a lot better i was never a huge fan
but it used to be a lot better now it's
clear there's a huge ideological shift
may you could probably say you know it's
almost homogenized look at any far left
figure show me a place where a far left
figure has been in any way demeaned or
demeaned or defamed i'm not aware of
them it's all towards the right and the
reason being clearly is that leftists
knew where to go
a decade decade and a half ago to gain
power and that's in the media i'll
actually i'll attest to that too because
my wikipedia page is fairly tepid it's
not really that bad
and that's an interesting indicator you
know i'm a fairly moderate person so
they're like you know but if you're
right-wing they write all of the worst
possible things about absolutely with no
consequence whatsoever
so something's got to be done about that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you